all right Scott Scott where are you from
where where' you grow up uh or Utah from
six years old to once I was six I moved
to Riverton Utah and that's where I was
born and
raised
and yeah are you Mormon my dad's a
Mormon I'm a Mormon but uh you know I've
had a hard growing up I kind of went
into the wrong crowd got into drugs here
and there psychedelics nothing too far
but you know Molly stuff like that the
wrong crowd always tried to fit in I've
done music my whole life
and just been getting closer to God
lately since I've been homeless for the
last six months
and I'm just keeping my faith forward so
you're staying in the be in Venice Beach
um yeah I was I was staying at the beach
for like no I was first so I got kicked
out in May and then um I stayed at
downtown a little bit in Salt Lake and
then I was staying at churches cuz no
homeless people were there I was like
staying in just in the back of churches
and then from there I went to Vegas for
about a month and then I started feeling
just un shaky I felt like the wrong
crowds were still around me and then I
hopped on a Greyhound to here and then I
was here for about a month on the beach
sleeping on the beach every night and
I've been at this safe place with the
youth they've been helping me out at spy
and then um I stayed I've been at the
they got me into a shelter finally and
that's where I've been at been getting
lost here and there still kind of
dealing with alcohol and cigarettes but
it's better than that um I've thought
I'd bipolar my my whole life but I
realized I'm not I'm not bipolar and so
medication is always breaking me down I
found Zyprexa which helps for me but I
just know I'm more than that and I have
a good strong mind of chakras and I'm
very connected to my spirit and anytime
I take medication I start eating way too
much sleeping too much watching too much
porn realistically and just all these
things that are just unhealthy and low
vibrational when I know I'm this this
very gifted talented person and my dad
wants to see that and I'm just trying to
make him proud cuz I don't want to be
his Junior my whole life you know I'm
the good-looking son I've always just
been oh Scotty's the best looking one
he's the best this one he's the best
that one and it's like I'm just in his
basement crying my entire life you know
going through breakup after breakup pain
after pain trying to blend in with
people that don't want anything for
me it's just how it's always been so I
know I know that's that's where I'm out
right now is to just make my dad proud
and my family I'm an uncle now I'm 24
but I want to make my nephew and my
niece proud because I I love them and I
just want to show them who I am that's
kind of where I'm at right now what was
your relationship like with your mom and
dad
so my dad he he had a really bad
childhood he never had a dad I never had
a grandpa uh his mom raised him and my
mother she and her
uncle um both their parents died when
they were like really really young they
got adopted by um my mom's um other
uncle and so there's like 13 of them and
so we've always had it really really
hard my my dad's died just died and just
I was they always wonder what was wrong
with me in school they thought I was
ADHD because I was never paying
attention in school I was really just I
love music I was always writing and
that's what they were just they're like
what's up with our son he's ADHD now
he's this now and I've been on over 20
different
medications and so and every time I was
on a medication I noticed I was the
worst person I was when I was on Aderall
I stole their car when I was 15 went
driving round up on I-15 going backwards
girl's house in my freaking underwear
doing crazy [__] that's just
ridiculous and I just know that's not
for so my parents are always like what's
up with him what's up with him but I
didn't start smoking until I was 15 as
well and bringing the wrong people to my
dad's house they moved out now they're
in Tennessee living their own life um
and it's been a bad relationship I uh
May 27th reason they kicked me I was
going through a breakup I had beer run
from Walmart and bashed in my parents
back uh fence I was just so sad I was so
painful they it's like every time I was
at their house they never accepted me as
who I was and then I broke the flat
screen TV it was mine which they gave me
whatever and then they were just they
were done from there I've you know I've
never hurt them I've never like gotten
their face or threatened them I've never
been a fighter I've never started a
fight never once and I I I broke you
know I just broke it too many times but
every time on Christmas anytime you know
they would just send me to the hospital
the mental hospital I've been to I'm 24
I've been to the mental hospital 11 15
times I have no clue they just always
send me there I I just need my dad to
accept me as who I am you know I've
never really done anything wrong um I
actually believe I'm a sociopath and it
it hurts me and that's why I know my dad
might be a psychopath because they burst
sociopaths and he might not like to hear
that but his life is [__] up and so is
mine but he believes in the good Lord
and so do I and that's what I'm finding
I'm glad I'm I'm glad I'm homeless cuz
what if I was 30 still living in my
parents then I would have never figured
it out so I want to have my own come up
my dad he does his own films I'm not
going to get get into that
but I I was always just a junior the
good-looking one the smart one the happy
one they so and then I had acne all over
I had acne up and down my face warts all
over me as younger eczema all over my
face people used to bully me make fun of
my legs you know like I was the scraw
like where I'm at right now I'm 180
whatever but I was 6'3 same height in
high school but I was 140 I was this
scrawny little dude I had to go to a boy
home when I was 15 because I was so
insecure about my weight My Size the way
I looked like I don't feel goodlooking
ever you know people just hurt me all
the time um people have jumped me uh
this girl who I never once touched like
she said you going to hit me in I never
hit her in the face and dude said Scott
you and I look at her for like
recognition and he decks me in the face
breaks my nose in 12 places um for no
reason and I never once hit him I even
forgave him after I had my home breaken
into by people that just want to rap
because they think because you rap you
have to sell drugs but I'm a decent
person you know I make music and that's
what I love doing and I will never give
up on that dream I know who I am am and
I don't need other people telling me
yeah I'm a little drunk right now yeah
I'm a little depressed right now yeah I
miss my family and it's Christmas and
I'm alone every single year but I have
purpose within me you know I have a real
passion I'm not just my dad's son I am
Scott Christopher Clin Jr but that has
nothing to do with anything I'm not here
to take your set you know you don't even
have to post this but like I'm trying so
damn hard and I know God sees me and I
know he's real and I'm a Mormon I don't
care what anyone has to say and I don't
know what what else so you're you're
you're interested in music I love music
what what how long you been into music
I've been doing it when I was eight my
brother was like come on you got he
would have me rap in front of his
friends so I'd say eight eight I was
rapping and then um it was like a higher
power was telling me to sing so I I'm
from Utah so there's some country twang
in there I love you know Jason alen uh
Morgan wall and all them and then uh
Eminem you were showing me a little bit
of your what you can do outside that's
the one thing that makes me happy um so
I kind of rap with Melody I learned that
a bit from Drake and all that you want
to share a little bit of that I can uh
you can give me any word in the world
what do you mean share a little bit of
what what you were singing outside um so
that's a song that's actually kind of
what led me to this whole situation
that's about the girl that um broke up
with me while we went on and off a
million times she's from Egypt um I was
really depressed and I found her on
online on Facebook and she was just
helping me I'd get drunk but whatever it
made me confident enough to talk to cuz
she's so pretty and um it's called uh
it's named it Cairo she's from Cairo and
it goes like and boy 50 did the beat the
beat's called imagination it goes um
you've been pacing us I don't Pace my
drinking it's dangerous yeah yeah yeah
yeah my whole life never knew something
like you was real started searching cuz
I was boy had nothing else to do when
you ended up here and you're surely real
so what's a twin flame and what the
[__] fade if a heart still breaks I'm
glad you're in my
heart I am in your head and you're in my
heart but my heart still braak yeah my
heart still breaks my heart still breaks
you could take me back this Maniac of
yours got a plan to catch of course I am
a flame you're a match of course but I
want to rematch of course what you going
to think about that of course not can I
working I've been working over time on
these beats funny thing is these flows
are inspired by you the only one
rightous for you the only wrong
righteous for you would always hold my
tongue but I B it for you never never
reply to text but I got time for you
like something about this doesn't even
really add a
battle so I live in my
imagination you came impr prove
manifestations no exaggeration so where
the [__] are you are you even who I
thought you were of course you are my
Egyptian queen of course you are
no one else going to fit in my shoes no
one else going to fit in your crown but
I felt sure I felt short so what's a
twin flame and what the [__] fade if a
heart still breaks I am in your head you
are in my heart but my heart still
breaks it's kind of like the four Shakra
Crown chakra in your head no one's going
to fit in my shoes solar plexus type
thing it's yeah that's great and you
you've been doing this pretty much not
this this is your only interest I don't
have interest in anything like obviously
like um I always realized it's good to
follow in someone's footsteps but I was
always rude to my dad I never saw how
much he loved me my dad's been married
to my mom for 32 years he's a Mormon
actor he puts all his faith in God and
I'm like you know what Dad he was 23
when he was doing um radio station I'm
like I'm 24 now he was working at
Wendy's I don't know my dad's whole
story but um I kind of want to follow in
his footsteps so I would do
podcasting um my dad told me to leave
the acting to him I would do just
podcasts I'm good with my voice rapping
music modeling um I'm not the most
confident in it but um I know I have
decent looks from what other people say
I guess we need our men to back us up
sometimes so yeah I can um and what's it
like living in the streets
here thank God I'm from Utah so I kind
of like the rain I don't mind it I say
the shelter I've gotten lost a few times
last week and I was lost my mom sent me
a speaker for Christmas and then I got
drunk and yeah I'm still you know I just
drink
I I don't see an issue with alcohol I
really don't see an issue I I believe
alcohol is the demon within you so if
you are dealing with gluttony if you are
dealing with lust then a lusting person
comes out and if you're dealing with
gluttony then something within that
person comes out that's what I think
about alcohol I don't find an issue with
alcohol I find what are you drinking
about I drink because I have issues
loving myself but I do love who I am I'm
just always moving forward and um it
closes my Consciousness sometimes you
know weed opens your third eye and
alcohol closes it so sometimes I drink
to regenerate myself and to just relax
um but back at home I was drinking to
escape something and I realized it was
just my parents there's nothing wrong
with that we love each other but you
know I'm 24 all my brothers moved out my
brother John he's 21 he's younger than
me and he's on doing his own thing and I
think I just felt really down on myself
I was eating food all day out of
shape watching nonsense on the internet
porn not going to lie it's normal um and
I just know that I just got to keep
going forward whether this works whether
this doesn't um you know I'm just trying
uh and and your Mormon upbringing you
think is something you want to continue
with I say Christian to manipulate God
so I can drink and smoke but uh yeah
yeah Mormon
upbringing
um yeah are you are you not supposed to
be drinking if you're a Mormon yeah so
here's how it is Judaism Christians
Catholic anyone that believes in God
it's all one and the same Mormons is
just the add-on there's the New
Testament the Mormons believe in the
Holy Bible the New Testament then the
Book of Mormon you know like way and
he's like I'm me this is the New
Testament cuz in a way we're all alive
in this time now so it's kind of the
book of Scott and the Book of Mormon
just ask for more it ask for uh no
coffee no pornography no sex before
marriage I [__] up on all those things
but like um it just asks for more I mean
you drink coffee and then you're tired
the next bit I think it just ask for
more and in return God says one day you
can have your own Universe I don't know
how much I believe in that but uh
Christian Catholics I'm a Christian you
know and Mormons will say yes we're
Christians too it's not like we're just
Mormons they just call themselves Church
to Jesus Christ a latterday Saints so
I'm I'm a Christian as of currently
because I well I just am I'm a Mormon
that is working through God and trying
his best and God sees how much a little
less I'm smoking cigarettes and drinks
and he sees I mean well look what's
happening right now you know I was on
the side of the street I have my shirt
off because I was helping the homeless
people I hate saying that type of stuff
on the internet you know but um I know
there's people that aren't 24 that don't
get the same perks as me so I was just
throwing my shirt around people need it
it's cold outside not for me but uh Los
Angel Los Angeles has been kind to you
since you've been here here or um I have
maybe I haven't been the kindness to Los
Angeles I've kind of been pissed off
lately I've been hearing not
voices just uh you know I'm an awaken
Spirit it is what it is um I've been
breaking the matrion since 19 for some
reason yeah so uh something like that
but um I know I'm chosen to do this so I
put my faith
above and I know where it's
going you know I go by a Scotty idiotic
and the reason I um go by that name
first people like you got to find your
sound you got to find this but it's I
felt you know I've been out of shape
I've been underweight I've been
overweight I've been skinny fat I've had
acne I've been Glutton I've been I've
been lustful it's like I felt every
single emotion so if whatever beat I
hear any beat any sound can be classical
any type of music it could be a country
song it could be literally any type of
it doesn't have to be rap it could be
anything and I will immediately tap into
what feeling I would feel during that
time because I feel like I felt every
single feeling and U people are bipolar
in this world and I would say triai pra
cuz cuz out of all the ones that do it's
a take us per needed you don't have to
wait a month to see if it works just to
see it [__] you over and then you have
to set it down again you know and then
wait for it to come off it's zexa is a
good medication if you are bipolar but I
know I'm not bipolar you know I uh don't
really know empathy and that's why I
believe in the filic energy because I
feel like they're more empathetic
towards me you know and I love God but
I'm a sociopath and that's fine I've
never done anything wrong I've never
done anyone dirty and I think that's
what's so beautiful about how do you
describe
sociopath well I don't really feel
empathy towards anyone like no but I
want to tell you my name and blow up off
your thing but I like you because you
respect me and you're a smart individual
I can tell so I like more brain I'm more
of a brain type of person you know if I
wasn't when I thought I was bipolar this
is that I would have done the Army but I
was on medication I would have been a
cop a detective because I've always
loved watching like True Crime Mr
balling I've always loved watching that
because I love seeing them just [__]
with someone's head make them think they
don't know that they know and then they
just capture them in the moment I think
that's dope so like whenever I fall for
a girl I love a girl cute to cool cuz I
like cute but I like a girl that knows
brain and she knows who I'm talking to
so like I fell in love with a girl on
the other side of the world I hate how
people say you can't fall in love
through the phone like what are you
talking about you know there's no sexual
relationship you know nothing's going on
you're just falling in love with who she
truly is there's no differences if I was
talking to her right now and she was
sitting on that couch right there so I
love who I just like brain I don't so
people think uh like you know out there
he was telling me you have some
subscribers what I'm like okay well I
could still if anything that made me
want to walk away no offense but it's
like that that doesn't move me money
doesn't move me money decimals it's all
just the force Shakra in my opinion
heart love Envy Pride I'm a very smart
individual so when someone Taps into my
conscience and respects me as an
individual as a mind smart person you
know that's why I like Andrew Tate so
much right now he's going through his
own [__] we don't need to get into that
but he's a very smart individual and
he's helped me out in very many ways and
I stand up for him you know I think uh
but I'm still my own person but that's a
smart individual to me he's helped my
brain I when I was very depressed and I
felt like I was seeing things or
whatever but I was just Awakening
through my Kini I I was looking for
people I was listening to Billy Carlson
19 Keys Alan Watts Terence McKenna Joe
Rogan and it's like the I just love
brain you know um that's the way I see
it and I'm just glad I have my dad and
that who loves God you know because or
I'd be doing some dumb [__] but I I just
I just rap I just love music and that's
what I that's just what I cope with do
you have any regrets in your life
anything you wish You' done different I
wish I didn't the first girl I cheated I
mean I cheated on my first girlfriend
and I was 16 she was 18 no I mean she
was dated from 16 to 18 I cheated on her
uh another girl didn't even give me no
other girl even got me hard she was just
all I wanted it didn't even no girl even
touch my I don't know what I was doing I
think it just uh built up my ego and
then it um I've dated two girls for real
her and then the girl from egyp they
were both about two years and I didn't
cheat on the second one I just let it go
to [__] because I was so doubtful of my
own self cuz she was so pretty so if
anything I wish I just put more faith in
girls and I've always had this issue
that like girls don't like me like they
either think I'm a rapper or they think
I'm just funny and if I'm not funny or
cracking a joke or if I'm not drunk that
I can't talk to them so I had this issue
where I just get drunk to like I'd get
drunk before anything so I can hang out
with people like I just always had this
fear that no one likes me I don't think
you like me I don't think anyone really
likes me that's always been my issue is
just doubting who I am in the mirror I
went to therapy after therapy as a young
person got kicked out of therapy
sessions just always with this belief
that people don't like me um my good
therapist Jo whatever you want to call
him um he told me I'm the perfectionist
you know there's the perfectionist the
worrier of uh mental illness and I'm the
perfectionist I just I when I was
younger if my I would look in the mirror
all day when I was in eighth grade my
hair had to be perfect I even wore
bronzer in eighth grade just because I
didn't like I didn't think I was tan
enough I had to be tan um so I dealt
with eczema warts acne all over but I
always had to look perfect so then I
started giving up on myself and just
drinking more so I felt good enough and
I started dressing stupid and just
getting kicked out of the house I'm just
a perfectionist of therapy you know like
if you know therapy you know what I mean
just I'm just the perfectionist and you
know my jaw is crooked that one thing
[__] I didn't even ever know and then
I saw a Pham flip back backwards and it
just messed with my head and it stopped
me and you know I had a finally blown up
on the internet I had 72.4k on uh Tik
Tok I had two videos get 1.2 million 1.5
million and then um uh we got in a car
wreck me and my friend he was driving he
was younger I'm not going to lie he was
17 I was 21 I I was telling him I should
drive there's no excuse he he was drunk
he wasn't that drunk but I should have
drove or anything we T-boned a cop car
of all cars if anyone knows Scotty
idiotic that's what happened to me he
T-Bone the cop car the cop flew into a
pond I'm the only one that got hurt I
have the scar right here here my face
got bashed in um the friend I was
friends with at the time he took a
picture of it 4 days later I see me on
Facebook he's telling people I'm there
I'm like this is my friends filming me
with my head's down you don't even know
if I'm dead that was uh New Year's Eve
2020 and I woke up 2021 technically and
um got a settlement and then I got manic
again or whatever you want to call it
thought I was coold flexing my money on
the internet got my Camaro stolen got
everything I got stolen from the
settlement of that and since then it's
just been [__] everything I have my mind
my body my own Spirit my body's strong
now I'm I'm ripped now I have I'm
muscular now I have abs now I'm I know
I'm good-looking I don't care that's
really what it all builds up to I'm
still me like your parents your parents
kicked you out yeah and I'm so glad they
did cuz I'm going to prove to them this
time that I'm Scotty idiotic like it's
going to happen sometimes being angry or
having having feelings like that can
motivate you to do the right do
something great if I'm so if I'm in my
parents house then I'm going to I'm
feeling down on the fact that I that I'm
living on my parents I'm going to want
to drink more I was more depressed my
parents house because I could always put
on a movie I could always go to my room
and jerk off I'm a dude it is what it is
uh I could always just go get drunk I
could always call a girl on the internet
I could always go on Kick and omegal and
screw around and be this and be drunk
and depend on alcohol right but since
I've been out on my own all it's had is
uh rap music uh workout workout workout
food food food you know it's like now I
know I'm my own individual are you still
drinking yeah but I it's not a problem
to me it was it's never been a problem
to me I believe that addiction is just
uh if all we are as reput ition of
thoughts like an affirmation right that
addiction isn't necessarily real it's
just that repetition of thought and what
we believe helps us in that moment
that's why people say you can chew on
sunflower seeds because you can chew on
sunflower seeds and then you can make
that to repetition everything I think I
need a cigarette I could just
immediately go down and do 10 push-ups
it's the same thing you could just
transmute it to something else like
sexual transmutation so I don't jerk off
I could just immediately transmute it to
something else I'm thinking of a
cigarette okay let me snap my fingers
five times and make that my addiction
let me make uh saying hello to someone
addiction I can just transmute
absolutely anything take all the energy
and just let it flow through my chakras
you know so I'm for Kobe a ball hog for
life I'm 242 to the four chakra of the
sacral chakra going to my fourth chakra
where my oral is learned that from 19
keys to my third eye and forever I'll
just uh you know what even says in the
Bible thou who uh abstain sex from his
own wife is even more powerful so I do
not I don't not believe I'm a sexual
transer all the most famous minds and
rich people of all time have known that
sexual trans mutation is the gateway to
pause time if we live in the third
dimension through that of the phone then
if you throw your phone away and uh some
monks believe that if you live in
silence for 4 days you start hearing
voices in your head but those are not
voices that's your ancestors that's your
own mind calling and once you live
through that and I have access to
Kundalini energy at 24 years old through
my crown to my chakra when I was young I
used to think of snake I had this OCD
that a snake was in my cup my friend
would say there's a snake in my boot
like the Kundalini Rising so it's
finally risen and I'm only 24 so I'm
pretty proud of
that that's the sounds of the chakras a
lot of meditation and uh you got a lot
going on in your mind oh so much but
I've learned how to utilize it utilize
it back to the give me any word just
watch this trust me any word you can
think of it give me big any word right
now
S I am on top of this feel like right
now back to the fact that I'm Scotty
pimping when I'm siding right off with
this NJ with a shot I'm talking and
still with no opposite I've been looking
all around and I've been waiting for a
mo and I taking it up with saying I
don't really got to condone it I can do
it my own way I don't really got to cut
this I get it right there when I'm do it
with my discussion sold sold to who will
you can know that over yo up on the beat
I go and [__] r that and I'm doing it
I'm doing it like codak when I F in my
own colors the orange the mor endorphin
to an orph and I'm feeling right there
take it every moment when I hit him with
the likely I to the top of this I'm
feeling the metrop of this tring then sh
me who Biggy and then calling this I was
feeling suicidal on that H line 1800 I
really got my time I've been getting it
any moment wrecking I'm Wrecking I'm
about it going talking out the stadium
the craning the devil when I get it
right there baby girl want you let go I
ain't worried about it I'm working
around it got my voice and she feeling
it now got a choice and not throwing the
sound you ain't throwing it tow cuz I
know what I'm about see it's really got
the top you don't believe me well this
is his present is this thing beside me
in this mic or whatever the hell is the
assignment take with your alignment the
ran building was getting whipped on one
every day of the class sping at the
teacher on a ra ass doing and I'm back
up to the top of this it's got to yet
got who the [__] going to talk this [__]
huh you got a lot in that that that was
like on easy mode you got a lot in your
head yeah I'm glad for that yeah you
you'll Mell it with age and hopefully do
something great yeah I'm trying um well
you know like Neil from The Matrix
that's like kind of Andrew take calls
himself he learned from the computers or
whatever so uh my third eyes is very
very strong and I had all this
information thr whenever I was depressed
I was watching movies Leonardo DiCaprio
James Franco those are my two favorite
actors went through all their movies so
any time I was depressed I'd eat a bunch
of food 12 donuts and eat it in Crispy
Cream in two seconds um and I would just
watch tons of movies or if I was down
I'd watch all these YouTubers nek Aiden
Ross I would just watch them anytime I
was bad and I would crutch on them every
single time I was down bad so like I've
always prayed and I've always kept my
faith going but anytime I felt bad on
myself I'd be on the alone in the
basement just consuming what the hell
ever so it's like I flipped the script I
never needed a computer and now it's
like my the computer in my mind unlocked
and it's like I'm Scott from X-Men you
know what I mean so it's like you know I
saw I met Morpheus I've seen Darth Maul
I've seen real ghost like Kanye said
kids see ghosts um I've seen some trippy
[__] in my life bring forth the force of
the force forever so yeah oh you're an
interesting young man yeah I'm chosen
they're letting the Scots outside you
know and religion plays a big part in
your in your life or no
um or not really God just God himself I
I believe if um if rap is my job then um
it' almost be hypocritical to like go
around and be all holy about it I don't
need to go around and tell people I'm
see this is me still learning I know God
gave me this opportunity so sure I'm a
Mormon sure I'm a Christian sure
whatever you want to call me but I I
should keep that behind me you know what
I mean cuz my job is music my dad
doesn't go around telling people all the
time my dad went on a mission he did
this his now he doesn't go around and
say you know what I mean that's just
what he who he is you like your dad um
as I've been homeless I've learned to
respect him more than anyone on this
planet because he's been with my mom for
32 years he's been all over the world
he's uh done a film with NCIS he's done
Mormon movies he's always kept his faith
above he's never even sworn swore one
time in NCIS and it's like uh he's just
he's just my dad the older we get the
more I think we learn to love and
respect always told me that too my dad
also told me when he was young when I
was younger this is what people need to
know if you going through a rough
childhood he said um life's kind of like
yin and yang well that's my wording but
he was like you know you've had such a
terrible childhood I promise you just
wait around when you're older you will
figure it out 23 22 21 those were some
hard years for me but 25 like I'm 24 and
a half May 5th 99 I'm 24 and a half and
like I'm so ready to see like I can't
wait to be 25 cuz I promise 24 is just a
fun year but I'm still all ahead so like
your brain really starts figuring itself
out 24 I guess we all go through these
quarter life crisises and mine's just
mine was hard mine was rough because
I've had I've always I've listened to
way too much music now my parents are
said don't listen to that don't listen
to that I mean I'm not going to listen
now because I'm doing it but uh yeah I'm
just me I'm not my dad's son I've never
been that I'm not some industry plant
I'm Scotty idiotic and I've been working
my ass off I've never once stopped with
music and now it's like well even though
I stopped to watch movies and stopped to
do this and I so low on myself well now
I have so much dope [__] to rap about to
put in my Rhymes and so so much random
things to say you know yeah I'm a big
fan of going all in yeah thank you I can
see that congratulations on your success
I heard a bit about you and good job on
that man no it's all I've ever done
since I was a little kid is photography
is photography yeah yeah I'm trying I'm
still a yeah I'm not the best photograph
never tried anything else so it's like I
think I think that's that's the way to
either find out that you're meant to do
this or not God bless you hope you keep
going man don't stop
ever what would you say is the most
important less you've learned so far in
your life most important lesson I've
learned I want to say something that
people have heard try something else
um I would just say All Above All unless
you're like truthfully like physically
impaired I would say just just focus on
your body because when music wasn't
working for me when I couldn't get that
flow right I would just say the number
one thing was just walking like you know
a song by Hopson actually saved my life
I was actually suicidal at a few times
in my life genuinely and um I felt so
insecure by my body to where I believed
every person in the neighborhood was
going to judge me you know I'd say just
uh I would just smoke weed I'd smoke a a
few bows and I'd just go out walking in
the middle of the night or not even that
I would just it would be 3:00 a.m. so no
one saw me I was that insecure um I'd
say if you're feeling low on yourself
just put your headphones in grab your
dog or whatever the [__] and uh just go
walking because your body your body
means something to you and it means
something to other people too which is
[__] up so I would say uh just stay
with your body if your mind isn't right
focus on your body if your mind's all
there relax write something I would just
say body everyone's got to be working
out if you got two feet and you can move
God bless anyone who can't just just
walk work on your body eat healthy don't
I don't even believe in eating healthy
just believe you're eating healthy it's
the Law of Attraction you know eat
healthy and believe you're eating
healthy enjoy yourself enjoy the food
don't get too crutch to the fact that
when you think you're eating something
unhealthy then you're actually just
going to [__] yourself up and do less so
just believe you're doing all right and
you're more likely to go to the gym
you're more likely to do that I'd say
just just walk there's nothing wrong
with walking there's nothing wrong with
a treadmill in your basement there's
nothing wrong with walking in place or
just yoga anything I would say my body
just sticking to your body that's me
though humans are meant to move yeah
we're meant to work all right Scott
thank you so much for sharing your
thoughts and story and I wish you lots
of luck yeah you as well Mark right yeah
Mark pleasure thank you for having me
nice to meet you Scott you too
thanks